حيث قال رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي ان
مثوله امام قاضي التحقيق اليوم هو ثمر
جديده من ثمرات ما وصفه بالانقلاب وقد تم
الابقاء على الغنوشي في حاله سراح بعد
التحقيق معه فيما يعرف بقضيه تكفير
الامنيين ولد وصوله لمقر القطب القضائي
لمكافحه الارهاب للموتور امام قاضي
التحقيق اكد الغنوشي ان ما سماه الانقلاب
اليوم لا يستهدف النهضه فقط بل كل
الكيانات الوطنيه معتبرا ما يتعرض له
اتحاد الشغل مظلمه تستهدف جامعه تونسيين
على حد تعبيره
رسوم عاجز عن مواجهاتنا
بالوسائل الديمقراطيه فلوجه الى استخدام
القضاء ونحن بان الخطا يتعافى وان القضاء
لم
يسير معهم في هذا الطريق
ما هو ثمر من ثمار الانقلاب
الانقلاب الذي ليس هو ضد النهضه فقط وانما
كل الكائنات الوسيطه وكل الاحزاب وكل
النقابات نحن نناصر
الديمقراطيه والمناصر المجتمع المدني
ونناصر الاتحاد الشغل ونعتبر انما يتعرض
له اتحاد الشغل بسبب هو مظلمه نزلت
الاتحاد فقط وانما التونسيين